Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Was ist eigentlich los in den anderen europäischen Ligen? Dieser Frage gehen wir im Rasenfunk Kurzpass jetzt immer wieder nach. Und heute blicken wir nach Frankreich auf die Ligue 1. Und am Telefon habe ich zugeschaltet, Kickerredakteur Hardy Hasselbruch. Hardy, schön, dass du dir Zeit für den Rasenfunk nimmst. Hallo. Das freut mich sehr. Wir wollen heute über die Ligue 1 sprechen und völlig überraschend thront da eine Mannschaft über allen anderen Paris Saint-Germain. Wo kamen denn die auf einmal her?
Paris Saint-Germain ist natürlich auch in der Historie des französischen Fußballs ein junger Verein. Er ist 1970 gegründet, war immer so was wie ein künstlicher Verein in der Hauptstadt. Passt natürlich auch zu dem Zentralismus, der in Frankreich vorherrscht, weil dafür in alle Wege über Paris. Also musste die Hauptstadt natürlich auch ein Verein haben, weil bis dato alle anderen Versuche mehr oder weniger fehlgeschlagen waren. Es gibt Red Star Paris, es gibt FC Paris, es gab in den 80er Jahren mal Madra Racing Paris, ein ähnlich künstlicher Verein, wie es auch Saint-Germain immer war und wahrscheinlich auch bleiben wird.
Ja, es hat sich alles ein bisschen potenziert. Ich denke, es wird an keiner Hörerin und keinem Hörer vorbeigegangen sein, welche Spiele inzwischen bei PSG so alles spielen. Und dementsprechend ist auch der sportliche Erfolg in der Liga. 17 Punkte liegt man derzeit vor dem AS Monaco, hat nur zweimal verloren, 95 Tore in 31 Spielen erzielt. Das sieht alles sehr erfolgreich aus. Und dennoch habe ich den Eindruck von Deutschland ausbetrachtet, Hardy, dass der Erfolg von PSG eigentlich gar nicht mehr wirklich an der nationalen Liga bemessen wird.
Nein, das ist ein Schmuck-Beiwerk, sage ich mal, dass man die nationalen Titel einfährt, auch wenn es im letzten Jahr unterbrochen worden ist durch den Sieg von AS Monaco in der Meisterschaft. Aber die hatten auch zugegebenermaßen eine sehr starke Mannschaft mit sehr viel Potenzial. Die Folgen sind bekannt. Man hat Monaco zur Hälfte leer gekauft, was natürlich auch dem russischen Düngemittel-Oligarchen sehr zu pass kam. Da konnte er erst mal wieder ein paar Einnahmen akquirieren.
Der dann vermutlich der Besitzer von Monaco ist, wenn ich das jetzt richtig schließe.
So ist es. Also der AS Monaco ist eigentlich seit Jahrzehnten jetzt auch schon mehr oder weniger in der Hand von russischen Besitzern. Der Düngemittel-Oligarch Dimitri Rybolovlev nutzt Monaco eben so als Geldanlage wie auch verschiedene Kunstwerke, von denen er sich ab und zu trennt. Von daher hat er jetzt auch seine Geschäfte mit der Mannschaft gemacht. Nach der meiste Saison im Vorjahr hat er, wie gesagt, ein halbes Dutzend Spieler für Roundabouts 250 bis 300 Millionen einfach verkauft, um damit seinen Geldsäckel wieder aufzufüllen.
Da rollt der Euro. Aber abgesehen von diesen wirtschaftlichen Themen und auch abgesehen von allem Wirbel rund um Neymar – wir haben im Vorgespräch schon ganz kurz darüber gesprochen, es ist unglaublich, wie viele News man findet, wenn man einfach nur Neymar googelt – was ist denn das für ein Fußball, den PSG spielt in der Liga? Kann man den gleichsetzen mit dem, was man in der Champions League von ihnen gesehen hat?
Ja, in etwa schon. Man muss einfach sagen, PSG veranstaltet in der Liga einfach Trainingsspiele und das ist, sage ich mal, vergleichbar mit dem, was in der Bundesliga und Bayern München passiert. Das ist in etwa die gleiche Situation, dass eine Mannschaft über allem droht und, sage ich mal, selbst in Topspielen dann Versuche an der Mannschaft starten kann, je nachdem, ob es verletzte Spieler gibt, ob es gesperrte Spieler gibt. PSG kann so viel nachschieben aus der zweiten Reihe, dass es eigentlich zumindest in der Liga nicht auffällt. Also was die hinten dran haben, ist schon, ja, sage ich mal, die doppelte Mannschaft. Nicht von ungefähr kommt es ja auch, dass deutsche Nationalspieler wie Kevin Trapp oder auch der so hochgelobte Julian Draxler nur eine untergeordnete Rolle spielen und eigentlich nicht mehr als eine Platzhalterfunktion haben.
Und ist das denn auch schön anzuschauen? Also es ist natürlich sehr offensiv. Sie haben die meisten Schüsse aufs gegnerische Tor pro Spiel mit weitem Abstand, die meisten erzielten Tore. Sie haben zu 63 Prozent den Ball durchschnittlich und eine hohe Passquote. Aber macht es auch Spaß, die Liga-Spiele vom PSG zu sehen?
Ach ja, sie sind recht unterhaltsam, würde ich mal sagen, weil auch die müssen den Gegner erstmal aufarbeiten, im Prinzip. Weil die Gegenwehr ist durchaus vorhanden. Auch gegen kleine Clubs aus der unteren Tabellenhälfte, da müssen sie schon was arbeiten. Also nicht von ungefähr, da kommt jetzt zum Beispiel auch eine der zwei Niederlagen aus Straßburg, dem Neuling aus dem Elters. Und natürlich ist es so, dass PSG überall erwartet wird, vor allen Dingen dann bei den, sage ich mal, wichtigen Spielen, wie zum Beispiel Marseille oder Lyon. Also da tun sie sich dann auch schwer, weil auch die beiden Mannschaften sind gut aufgestellt und können ab und zu mal Schwächen dieser großen Mannschaft nutzen.
Ja, dann lass doch mal auf die beiden blicken. Wie ist denn die Situation bei den beiden engsten Verfolgern in Anführungszeichen von PSG?
Ja, dazwischen steckt ja zwar nach wie vor Monaco, es ist aber so, mit Olympique Marseille verbindet PSG schon immer eine innige Feindschaft, die einfach trotz aller Künstlichkeit des Clubs aus Paris gewachsen ist. Das sind im Prinzip die Pole, weil in Frankreich ist es so, darf man nicht vergessen, die Hälfte aller Fußballfans sind im Prinzip Marseille-Fans. Das ist eine Tatsache, die man hier nicht oft genug betonen kann. Marseille ist also der Nabel der Fußballwelt in Frankreich, auch gewachsen, besonderes Ambiente in dieser südfranzösischen Hafenstadt an der Côte. Die Fans sind extrem verrückt. Vielleicht hängt es auch damit zusammen, dass in Marseille eben sehr viele ehemalige Afrikaner und Nordafrikaner leben. Da ist ein bisschen mehr Heißblut unterwegs als anderswo in Frankreich. Lyon ist natürlich eine gewachsene Mannschaft, die nicht umsonst zu Beginn des Jahrtausends sieben Titel in Folge geholt hat. Sie hatten damals eine extreme Dominanz, die jetzt PSG ausfüllt im Prinzip. Lyon hat natürlich auch eine besondere Rivalität zu PSG, weil sie sind im Prinzip von den Parisern jetzt abgelöst in ihrer Dominanz. Wobei Lyon auch jetzt wieder auf einem guten Weg ist mit vielen guten, jungen Spielern, die sie unter Vertrag haben. Sie haben jetzt ein neues Stadion, was lange gedauert hat, bis es endlich fertig wurde. Lyon ist ein finanzstarker Verein, mittlerweile auch mit chinesischem Geld unterwegs, während Marseille einen amerikanischen Besitzer hat, den Frank McCormack, der sich allerdings, weil er aus dem American Football kommt, nicht großartig einmischt, sondern nur die Taler zur Verfügung stellt.
50 plus 1 gibt es demnach nicht in Frankreich?
Nein, damit würden sich die Franzosen auch nicht aufhalten wollen, weil sie brauchen eben das Geld von Investoren. Weil es gibt immer noch sehr viele Vereine, die am Existenzminimum nagen, sind viele Kleinstadtvereine dabei, die froh sind, wenn sie den Kopf über Wasser halten, finanziell. Deswegen hat man sich auf sowas Schwieriges, Kompliziertes und vielleicht nicht ganz Korrektes wie 50 plus 1 eingelassen.
Gut, ob das für den Investor dann befriedigend genug ist, jemanden über Wasser zu halten, ist eine andere Frage. Aber das ist auch eine andere Diskussion. Wir haben jetzt hinter PSG, wo ich jetzt mal vermuten würde, die meisten Hörerinnen und Hörern sind da die sportlichen Stützen bekannt, haben wir Monaco, Marseille und Lyon. Kannst du uns mal kurz durch die Vereine durchführen? Wer sind da die entscheidenden Spieler?
Ja, um oben anzufangen, natürlich sind bei PSG Leute wie Neymar oder auch Mbappé jetzt inzwischen extrem wichtig. Cavani nicht zu vergessen. Top-Toriger noch, aber da kann man eigentlich bis hinten durchgehen. Die einzige Position, wo aktuell der Schuh drückt, ist die des Links-Verteidigers, wo sie mit Bershish oder auch mit Gürsava nicht ganz so stark besetzt sind. Da werden sie sicherlich auch was tun. Kritik entzündet sich auf der rechten Seite hin ab, wie an Dani Alves, der mit seinen 34 Jahren nicht mehr die beste Form hat. Das ist auch kein Wunder bei seiner Kilometerleistung, die er im Laufe seiner Karriere abgeliefert hat. Ansonsten ist es eine Mannschaft mit extrem viel Potenzial, was immer aufgestockt wird. So wie ich das einschätze, werden die Katarer nie aufhören. Es ist nebenbei auch für die Kataris eine ganz wichtige Lokomotive für ihre eigene WM 2022. Da muss man einfach mal davon ausgehen, dass sie Geld ohne Ende haben. PSG ist nichts anderes als ein Staatsverein aus Katar, muss man ganz deutlich sagen.
Mit dem Ziel, das Image von Katar zu verändern, das finde ich noch ein interessantes Aspekt.
Das ist eine Imagegeschichte, das ist ein Politikum gewesen. Da haben zu den Anfängen Leute wie Sarkozy, Platini hingeholfen. Es ging damals auch darum, dass man mit Katar Handel treiben konnte. Es ging natürlich um Waffengeschäfte. Das ist in Katar zumindest ein Politikum. Die großen und teuren Entscheidungen trifft der EMEA selbst. Der Präsident Nasser al-Khelaifi ist sozusagen der verlängerte Arm des EMEAs. Er versucht, bei PSG das Beste rauszuholen. Das Beste ist eben der Gewinn der Champions League, was er seit seinem Amtsantritt im Jahre 2011 ohne Unterlass verfolgt hat. Bisher fehlt der krönende Erfolg, was vielleicht auch ein bisschen mit einer gewissen Überversorgung – damit meine ich die Bezahlung der Spieler – und vielleicht auch einer etwas inkonsequenten Trainer-Auswahl liegt. Da haben sich schon viele daran versuchen dürfen, namhafte Trainer wie Carlo Ancelotti bis hin zu Emery, jetzt zwischendurch der ehemalige Nationaltrainer Laurent Blanc. Es ist ein bisschen wie im Teufelskreis, dass diese Mannschaft in der Regel im achten Finale oder vierten Finale der Champions League rausfliegt. Das ist aber auch nur ein Zeichen, dass der Weg, den PSG geht, durchaus noch steinig ist, trotz aller Kohle, die da im Hintergrund steht. Alles kann man nicht kaufen, selbst wenn man 222 Millionen für Nehme ausgibt und etwas weniger für das Talent Mbappé, damals nur 18-jährig. Dann zeigt das, wie schwer der Weg von PSG ist. Bei Monaco herrscht eine etwas andere Philosophie. Sie suchen sich für relativ teures Geld die besten Talente in Frankreich und woanders aus. Man scheint in Ruhe arbeiten zu können, damit meine ich auch den portugiesischen Trainer Leonardo Jardim, der eine sehr gute Aufbauarbeit leistet. Was ich vorhin schon erwähnte, ist natürlich schwierig, den Abgang von einem halben Dutzend Hochkaräter zu kompensieren. In der jetzigen Saison sind aber auch da gute, talentierte Spieler dabei und man muss es einfach so sagen, in Monaco gibt es auch den Vorteil, dass sie in aller Ruhe konzentriert arbeiten können. Es gibt kein Medium in dem Sinne oder kaum Medien. Natürlich ist Monaco von der Konkurrenz der Ligue 1 schief angesehen. Das hängt unter anderem mit der Staatsstruktur zusammen. In Monaco muss das Geld, das die Spieler verdienen, nicht versteuert werden. Bei der Rückkehr des AAS Monaco in die Ligue 1 gab es auch große Probleme innerhalb der französischen Liga, weil die anderen Clubs aufbegehrt haben, um eine Kompensationszahlung von Monaco haben zu wollen. Um diesen Standortvorteil, den Monaco genießt, ausgleichen zu können.
Und was kam raus?
Es blieb ein wenig unklar. Es gab mal die Zahl von 52 Millionen damals, die Monaco an die anderen Clubs abgeben sollte.
An alle 19 Clubs? Ja.
Das ist aber nie offiziell bestätigt worden. Man hält das unter der Decke. Man kann aber davon ausgehen, dass der Club schon etwas an Kompensationen zahlt. An die übrigen Clubs. Aber auch da wird der Deckel drauf gehalten. Marseille ist mittlerweile auf dem Wege der Besserung, nachdem sie jahrelang ein Siegtum unter der Ägide erlebt haben. Drei Fuß, wo dann die Witwe versucht haben, die Geschicke des Vereins zu lenken, aber nicht bereit waren, noch großartig Geld reinzulegen. Das hat sich inzwischen geändert. Aus meiner Sicht ist das sehr positiv zu bewerten, weil ein starkes Marseille gehört einfach zu Ligue 1 dazu. Vor allen Dingen, weil sie haben das schönste Stadion, das alte Velodrom und sie haben eben die verrücktesten Fans. Wenn man sieht, dass Marseille im Moment einen Durchschnitt von 45.000 pro Spiel hat, dann ist das auch schon hinweislich darauf, wie heiß die Leute da auf Fußball sind. Das ist überhaupt eine interessante Feststellung, dass der Fußball in Frankreich nicht zuletzt auch durch Neymar im Aufwind befindet. Das Ansehen des Fußballs ist gestiegen. Die Zuschauerzahlen haben sich stark verbessert in den letzten Jahren. Selbst Lyon hat im neuen Stadion jetzt einen Durchschnittsbesuch von über 44.000. Das ist für französische Verhältnisse sehr gut, weil es eben auch die anderen Kleinstadt-Clubs gibt, die mit rund 15.000 im Schnitt leben müssen. Aber wenn man zum Beispiel sieht, dass das gallische Dorf Gengon einen aktuellen Durchschnitt von 14.144 hat, dazu muss man aber auch wissen, dass die Stadt nur 8.000 Einwohner hat. Also es ist alles relativ zu sehen im Prinzip. Nur wie gesagt, die Akzeptanz des Fußballs ist gestiegen. Trotz großer Konkurrenz darf man nicht vergessen, in Frankreich beispielsweise durch rugby. Das ist für uns Deutsche kaum nachvollziehbar, aber dort ist es eben so, dass speziell im Midi im Süden Frankreichs, um das genauer zu sagen im Südwesten Frankreichs, ist das die große Leidenschaft der Leute. Wenn ich zum Beispiel hier die Zuschauerdurchschnittszahl des FC Toulouse sehe mit knapp 16.000, dann lacht sich der ortsansässige Rugby-Club Stade Toulouse darüber tot, weil die haben das Doppelte. Die haben ein eigenes Stadion und da sind, sage ich mal, die Schwerpunkte ganz klar verteilt zugunsten des Rugbys.
Ja, da liest du jetzt gerade bei den Six Nations auch nicht ganz so gut für Frankreich, aber das ist jetzt ein komplett anderes Thema. Aber eine Frage würde mich da schon noch interessieren, Hardy. Glaubst du denn, wenn jetzt durch so etwas wie den Neymar-Wechsel tatsächlich das Zuschauerinteresse gestiegen ist, dass das auch nachhaltig ist? Denn ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, man guckt sich das jetzt gerne mal an. Wie spielt denn jetzt PSG? Wie spielen die ganzen großen Namen, die man da kennt? Aber eigentlich müsste es doch einem irgendwann auch wieder langweilig werden, weil einem ja völlig klar ist, ja gut, das wird jetzt wieder ein 1 zu 3, ein 0 zu 4.
Die Gefahr besteht natürlich, aber auch da haben wir den Vergleich in der Bundesliga. Das ist mit Bayern München genau dasselbe. Auch die haben permanent ihr Stadion ausverkauft. Auch wenn man sagen muss, das ist wie in Paris Eventpublikum, was ich immer ein bisschen kritisiere dabei. Das ist also Jubelpublikum im Prinzip. Und die können sich gar nicht satt gewöhnen an Siegen. Aber ich glaube auch, dass die Entwicklung in Frankreich und die Akzeptanz des Fußballs durchgehend positiv zu bewerten ist. Da spielt natürlich auch mit rein so was wie die verbesserte Infrastruktur nach der Euro 2016 in Frankreich. Darf man nicht vergessen, die Stadien sind anders geworden, ganz anders als zum Beispiel in Italien und haben inzwischen vielfach den Standard, den wir aus Deutschland gewöhnt sind. Von daher ist die Akzeptanz breit. Und ich glaube auch, es wird sich nachhaltig zum Positiven verändern. Ich sage mal ein Beispiel in einer Stadt wie Bordeaux, ein traditionsreicher Club, die haben mit dem neuen Stadion auch eine neue Akzeptanz. Sie sind bei knapp 25.000 Zuschauern im Schnitt. Während im alten Stadion waren sie schon froh, wenn sich 15.000 bis 20.000 versammelt haben. Und daran erkennt man eben auch, dass der Fußball am Wachsen ist dort.
Interessant. Was ist denn jenseits von den großen vier, über die wir jetzt gesprochen haben? Paris, Monaco, Marseille und Lyon. Wer sind denn so die Überraschungsmannschaften gerade oder die, wo man auch sagt, da lohnt es sich, Spiele anzugucken, weil die einen besonders attraktiven Fußball spielen?
Ich würde generell mal sagen, lohnen tut es sich überall. Weil überall schwere sehr viel Talente rum. Frankreichs Fußball ist sehr jung, muss man sagen. Die Mannschaften sind alle mehr oder weniger in einem Altersbereich von 20 bis 23 Jahren aufgestellt. Das ist auch die einzige Chance, die die vielen kleinen Clubs haben. Es gibt eine positive Entwicklung, zum Beispiel in Nizza. Auch dort sind chinesische Investoren unterwegs. Es gibt einen Traditionsverein wie FC Nantes, der mit Trainer Claudio Ranieri wieder auf die Füße gekommen ist. Es gibt Montpellier, die 2012 auch nochmal Meister waren, völlig überraschend damals mit Laurent Blanc, wo gute Arbeit gemacht wird. Es gibt den Ultratraditionsverein AS Saint-Jean, der allmählich wieder auf die Füße kommt. Mich persönlich würde es auch freuen, wenn Rassing-Strasburg im Osten der Republik sich dauerhaft in der Ligue 1 behaupten könnte, weil dort wird über den ehemaligen Karlsruher Marc Keller als Präsident und auch Financier teilweise des Clubs sehr gute Arbeit geleistet. Und Strasburg gehört eben zu den Ultratraditionsvereinen, muss man sagen, und tut der Liga auch durchaus gut. Jedenfalls besser als Clubs wie Angers, wie Amiens, wie Troyes oder Köln, muss man sagen. Das ist einfach der Unterschied, weil der Fußball lebt in allen Ligen von der Tradition und da gehört in Frankreich eben Rassing Strasburg absolut dazu.
Ja, interessant, welche Parallelen da manchmal auch zu Entwicklungen in der Bundesliga aufgemacht werden können. Du hast jetzt im Vorbeigehen einen Club genannt, über den ich noch gerne kurz sprechen würde, nämlich Nizza, wegen des Trainers Lucien Favre. Jetzt haben wir alle mitbekommen, der war häufiger hier in Deutschland im Gespräch und wird es vielleicht auch wieder im Sommer sein? Wie ist denn seine Situation bei Nizza?
Ja, er hat eigentlich sehr erfolgreich in Nizza gearbeitet, muss man sagen, mit einer guten Platzierung, sprich Europapokalplatz in der Vorsaison. Es ist nicht ganz einfach, in Nizza zu arbeiten. Der Präsident ist sehr mächtig, Jean-Marc Rivière. Er wird voraussichtlich auch bleiben, der Präsident. Es gibt chinesische Geldgeber. Lucien Favre ist im Vorjahr auch ein Mario Balotelli vorgesetzt worden, den er nicht unbedingt haben wollte, als schwierigen Charakter innerhalb der Mannschaft, der aber mittlerweile halbwegs funktioniert, sag ich mal. Er hat nach wie vor seine Qualitäten.
22 Tore.
Ja, natürlich, natürlich. Aber er ist halt schwierig vom Handling her, sehr eigenwillig, ist natürlich für das Publikum was Besonderes. Nizza hat mit Dante den typischen Favre-Spieler dazugeholt. Das ist seine rechte Hand auf dem Platz. Sie haben sehr große Talente. Es kommt nicht von ungefähr, dass dieser Corsiello in Köln jetzt so gut eingeschlagen hat. War in der vergangenen Saison einer der Topspieler bei Nizza. Hat dann in der neuen Saison etwas den Anschluss verloren, weil aber auch gutes anderes Spielermaterial da ist. Der Cyprien ist ein wunderbarer Fußballer im Mittelfeld. Der Seri ist ivorischer Nationalspieler. Sehr guter Mann war bei Barcelona im Gespräch. Und Nizza wird mit Sicherheit weiter im Kommen sein im französischen Fußball. Dazu haben sie eine kleine Allianz-Arena für die EM hingesetzt, sodass auch 40.000 Zuschauer empfangen werden können. Nizza ist Unwald von Marseille und entsprechend ist auch die Klientel relativ heißblütig dort vor Ort. Und ich traue OGC eine ganze Menge zu für die Zukunft, ob das dann weitergeht mit Lucien Favre, sei mal dahingestellt. Er hat einen Vertrag bis 2019, angeblich mit einer Ausstiegsklausel. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob er im Moment gewillt ist, zu tauschen. Weil ich sage mal, es gibt natürlich Gründe, um in Nizza zu bleiben. Da sage ich nur Strand, Wasser, Meer. Oder ob man das unbedingt mit der ehemaligen Industriestadt Dortmund tauschen muss.
Zum Beispiel. Okay, dann werden wir das einfach mal im Auge behalten. Wer sind denn so die herausragenden Spieler, die man jetzt vielleicht hier in Deutschland nicht kennt, die man dann auch noch nicht in der Champions League vielleicht gesehen hat? Auf wen kann man so achten, wenn man die Liga sich mal anschaut?
Ach, das ist ein hochinteressantes Kapitel, sage ich mal. Wenn man allein sieht, wie viele Leute der Nationaltrainer des Champs zur Verfügung hat zur Bildung eines schlagkräftigen Kaders und wer da dann alles rausfällt. Ich habe vor der Euro 2016 meine B- und C-Mannschaft aufgestellt, die immer noch wettbewerbsfähig wäre. Dann ist das sehr reichhaltig, was da alles noch unterwegs ist, sage ich mal.
Woher kommt denn das? Hat der französische Fußball ein so gutes Nachwuchskonzept etabliert oder woher kommen diese vielen jungen französischen Talente?
Sie haben seit Jahrzehnten die Nachwuchsleistungszentren. Sie haben jetzt das nationale Nachwuchsleistungszentrum in Clairefontaine. Davor hatten sie es in Vichy. Die Vereine arbeiten sehr gut am Nachwuchs. Ich bringe da immer gern das Beispiel in Auxerre, wo der extrem schlaue Trainer Giroud in der Ruhe der Kleinstadt in der Bourgogne eine hervorragende Arbeit gemacht hat und, sage ich mal, fast jede Saison vier, fünf Top-Talente rausgebracht hat. Ich habe hier gerade noch mal vor Augen die letzten Titel, die Frankreich im Juniorenbereich geholt hat, als da wären 2016 U19 Europameisterschaft und 2013 U20 Weltmeisterschaft. Da haben sie jeweils den Titel gewonnen. Ich sage mal, aus dieser U19-Mannschaft von 2016 ist jetzt schon mal das Übertalent MBAP dabei. Das war damals ein Turnier hier in Deutschland. Das ist nicht so großartig wahrgenommen worden, sage ich mal. Aber es war schon eine Zusammenfassung von großen Talenten. Unter anderem spielte damals auch ein gewisser Arid, Amine Arid, der jetzt bei Schalke 04 unter Vertrag steht, und auch ein Kevin Augustin, der jetzt bei Leipzig unter Vertrag steht. Und die anderen Spieler sind im Prinzip alle in der französischen ersten Liga unterwegs. Es gibt natürlich immer die Ausnahmen von der Regel, weil nicht alle aus dem Juniorenbereich schaffen es dann auch in den großen Fußball, im Seniorenbereich unterzukommen. Aber es gibt darüber hinaus noch andere Talente. Einer ist gelandet bei RB Salzburg, das will auch schon was heißen. Es gibt noch einen, der Toussaint ist bei Olympique Lyon unterwegs, der Blas, ein Superfußballer, ist noch in Gengen im gallischen Dorf. Und so kann man jetzt der Reihe nach aufzählen. Und wenn ich nur mal einige wenige Namen aus der U-20-Weltmeistermannschaft von 2013 nenne, dann beginnt das mit Paul Pogba, geht das weiter über Arreola, den jetzigen PSG-Torhüter, über den links-Verteidiger Dinje, bis hin zu anderen Spielern, die in der Regel alle im Ausland unterwegs sind. Das ist zum Beispiel auch so eine Geschichte, die französischen Ligue 1-Spieler wechseln sehr früh in gute ausländische Ligen, weil sie sehr gut ausgebildet sind. Und davon, von dieser Erfahrung, von dieser internationalen Erfahrung, von der immer so viel gesprochen wird, profitiert natürlich auch die nationale Mannschaft. Weil wenn sich die Jungs erst im Ausland durchsetzen müssen, dann sind sie auch anders gestehlt, als wenn sie ihr Eigenleben in der Ligue 1 führen.
Das hört sich alles nach einer insgesamt auch sehr interessanten Liga an. Also wenn ich mir auch alleine nur die Punkteabstände angucke aufs europäische Geschäft, da sind noch vier Vereine im Rennen und der Abstiegskampf ist auch recht spannend unten drin. Wie ist denn das Spielniveau in der Ligue 1? Du wirst ja selbst wissen, was wir hier mit der Bundesliga Woche für Woche vorgesetzt bekommen, in welchem Verhältnis reiht sich da die französische Liga ein?
Ja, das ist im Prinzip durchaus vergleichbar.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Kompliment war oder?
Nein, hier wird ja häufig geglaubt, nur die Bundesliga ist das alleinselig machende. Das ist mitnichten so, weil zum Beispiel die französische Liga inzwischen sehr spielstark ist. Trotz aller Unterschiede der einzelnen Vereine ist sie dennoch – sieht man mal vom PSG ab – recht ausgeglichen. Es gibt keine Freispiele, wo man hinfährt und auch leicht gewinnen kann. Das ist mitnichten so. Das gehobene Niveau hat sich jetzt zum Beispiel auch bei den Europa Cup-Spielen gezeigt, wo Frankreich bisher besser abschneidet, was den Koeffizienten angeht, als die Bundesliga. Man mag über diese Koeffizienten lachen, aber sie geben schon Anhaltspunkte über die Spielstärke einer Liga. Da hat Frankreich in den vergangenen Jahren hatte die Liga etwas den Anschluss verloren. Aber es kommt etwas nach. Wir werden es jetzt wieder sehen, wenn Leipzig gegen Marseille spielt. Das ist ein interessanter Vergleich. Sicherlich auch Aussage kräftig in Anbetracht der Tatsache, welche Liga ist wie gut. Marseille ist dritter, Leipzig ist auch noch im Rennen um die Champions-League-Siegplätze. Da kann man schon schauen, wie stark die Liga ist. Marseille hat inzwischen wieder eine schlagkräftige, gute Mannschaft, unter anderem mit dem Ex-Volksburger Luis Gustavo. Drumherum gibt es weitere gute Spieler. Thauvin ist Nationalspieler. Kostas Mitroglu, griechischer Toriger, ehemals in Gattbach groß geworden, dann Weg über Pireos und Benfica Lissabon gemacht. Da wird es schon einen entsprechenden Vergleich geben. Das ist auch sinnbildlich dafür, dass die französische Liga an Spielstärke durchaus zugenommen hat. Mag man auch daraus absehen, dass inzwischen auch viele Tore geschossen werden. Frankreich war für Jahre das Synonym des 0-0-Fußballs, weil die Trainer sich kaputt taktiert haben. Sie wollten nur nicht verlieren. Aber inzwischen fallen pro Spieltag fast 26 Tore im Schnitt, was natürlich auch für ein gewisses Spektakel in den Spielen spricht. Die Spiele sind offener geworden. Natürlich geht eine Vielzahl dieser Tore auf PSG. Aber auch die anderen Mannschaften spielen inzwischen recht offensiv. Nach meinem Dafürhalten ist die Attraktivität in der Liga inzwischen stark angewachsen.
Jetzt habe ich das Problem, das ich bei fast jedem Kurzpass bisher hatte, dass ich dann unglaubliche Lust bekomme, mich mal in diese Liga richtig tief reinzufuchsen, so wie du ja schon lange drin steckst. Das hört sich tatsächlich sehr interessant an. Ich danke dir sehr für deine Zeit und für dein Debüt im Rasenfunk.
Ich bedanke mich ebenfalls. Wie gesagt, da kann man jeden Tag drei Stunden darüber erzählen.
Ich biege mir sowas lieber nicht an.
Aber wie gesagt, du hast begrenzte Sendezeiten. Aber ich habe es gerne gemacht für dich, Max.
Das freut mich sehr. Das war Hardy Hasselbruch vom Kicker. Lieben Dank fürs Zuhören, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr könnt den Rasenfunk unterstützen, unter rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Und ihr könntet uns vielleicht mal den Kurzpass bei iTunes bewerten. Das würde uns da mal ein bisschen helfen. Da können wir noch ein paar Rezensionen vertragen. In diesem Sinne, danke fürs Zuhören und bis bald mal wieder, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Macht's gut, ciao.